[Musik]
wirklich nicht
hallo herzlichen fensters ellis welt
heute gibt es eine richtig tolle getränk
idee von mir und die ila und zwar werde
ich lamento verwerten dann ganz viele
länder auf der terrasse soll meine
freundin hat ganz viel im garten und es
wäre einfach viel gestartet wenn man
nicht damit anstellen würden deswegen
habe ich heute ein rezept für euch und
war werden wären da wenn du sirup
erstellen dem können wir dann verwenden
backen trinken
ich hab das ganze auch als geschenkidee
gemacht das heißt hier abgefüllt in die
kleine reagenzgläsern ihr könnt sie auch
in flaschen abfüllen und verschenken und
wirklich einfach gibt tausende von ideen
was man damit anstellen kann
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die
zubereitung spies und zeitig die
formalitäten für den lavendel verbrauchs
300 gramm zucker auf 400 milliliter
wasser eine zitrone nach belieben einen
zitronengras stängel und etwas na denn
zuerst einmal nehme ich jetzt den zucker
und das wasser muss gehe ich jetzt hier
in einem topf rein und da raus wird ist
ein zuckersirup gekocht heißt sie mir
schon was ich jetzt auf kochen wird sich
der zucker aufgelöst hat und kann
währenddessen schon mal die lavendel
slitan abdrucken
und zwar so wie habe ich die schönen
lila blüten und wir sind auch schon
welche diesen anspruch ein bisschen
abgetrocknet das ist aber gar nicht
schlimm verwenden wir jetzt so und jetzt
werde ich die angst vorm stengel
befreien und ihr könnt hier auch kleine
getrockneten anwendung verwendet werden
mit extra vielseitig also ich mache mir
auch mal sucht beckham für den
kleiderschrank hält die moz entfernen
habe ich in jedem kleiderschrank auch
bei samira vor allem sieht sehr lecker
habe ich aber auch schon damit gebacken
und frage wie einem taschen in der
türkei aber auch ich total lecker
[Musik]
etwa einen bund verwendet wird nicht
sucht das ist etwa ein glas voll
bisschen es insgesamt 70 gramm blüten
las ich kurz an der seite stehen den
zuckersirup habe ich übrigens umgefüllt
damit er schneller abkühlt wenn man den
zuckersirup jetzt ganz heiß über die
lavendelblüten fließt dann geht s
ätherische öl kaputt das heißt ich kühlt
ab auf etwa 60 grad und es mache ich
jetzt mit hilfe einer komplett mit
seinem kühlt dann geht es einfach ein
bisschen schneller weil sie jetzt kein
thermometer habt macht es einfach so
macht daran die finger probe zu
verstecken finger rein jetzt noch zu
heiß ich kann das nicht drin stecken
lassen
60 gerade etwa zwischen 50 und 60 ist so
dass das ding reingeht und auch mal zwei
drei sekunden drin bleiben kann ohne
dass es eben zu heiß wird macht mir
einfach die körper temperatur körper
thermometer probe den finger aber bitte
erst dann rein stecken wenn der zucker
sirup nicht mehr da ist also bisher
nicht zurück
[Musik]
jetzt der woche noch etwa 60 grad warm
jetzt kommen hier die blüten mit rein
[Musik]
deutschland
jetzt könnt ihr an der stelle gerne auch
das zitronengras hinzufügen
ich lasse es ist allerdings so pur weil
ich in einen reinen lavendel sirup haben
möchte dass zitronen kraft wenig später
wird das so wenn ich dann die limonade
hersteller und so könnt ihr den wänden
sirup dann später nämlich benutzen um
zum beispiel limonade zu machen ihr
könnt prosecco ausfüllen weckt aufführen
oder können sogar zum trinken von fuhren
böden verwenden
ich lasse es ist hier komplett abkühlen
sechs wochen später geht's dann weiter
fünf stunden später hat sich optisch
nicht viel verändert aber ich hab n sehr
hoch mal probiert und das noch richtig
lecker machen wenn das ganze ab seien
auch drücken
[Musik]
um dem serum ist haltbar zu machen kann
ich nicht einmal aufkochen lassen und
sprudelnd kochen lassen und dann in
einen schauplatz oder zum beispiel in
eine richtig schöne flasche und dann ist
verrichtet er über mehrere wochen oder
sogar monate haltbar
ich mache das ganze jetzt nicht wenn ich
verbinde das gleich weiter und zeigt
euch jetzt einmal wie ich die limonade
hersteller hier sieht jetzt aus wie in
einem chemielabor aber ich möchte euch
jetzt zuerst einmal zeigen wie es in
sirup fertigstellen
ich möchte jetzt tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen fernen denn ich würde thema
reihen
er war leicht eine phase aber keine
handelswaren und deswegen aber wir
könnten so lassen wollte ich natürlich
ganz schön ist aber ich möchte doch ein
bisschen was von werner wenzel tüte
haben sie taktieren sind taschen körbe
drauf gegeben in blau und pink dann
nehme ich es ab
und die braucht davon wirklich sehr sehr
wenig details geht jetzt ein kind sirup
hier ein kleines gefährt sagen die farbe
dann tauche ich mein pinsel rein mit dem
blau
wie ihr seht ich habe nur einmal rhein
gekippt und die farbe reicht schon aus
um dieses kleine gefäß zu färben und das
ist für mich auch perfekte fahrer wie
kommt ihr ziel mit rein und
wahrscheinlich braucht man einfach nur
mal zwei bis drei tropfen
[Musik]
natürlich den sirup einfach in der
flasche um und ich habe jetzt eine
flasche da war man holunderblütensirup
drin die habe ich jetzt ausgewaschen
etikett entfernt und habe ich eine
richtig schöne flasche für meinen sehr
gut und damit nicht leckeres gibt ein
trichter werde das ganze eben haltbar
machen wollen würde
solltet ihr diese flasche einfach ein
bisschen auskochen damit alle keime
getötet werden und dann können wir
wirklich im kühlschrank lagern
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch ein bisschen sirup
in reagenzgläser abgefüllt denn ich
finde den zero wird auch eine richtig
tolle geschenkidee und wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr daher noch jeweils eine blüte
reinstellen woche einstecken sinkt dann
wahrscheinlich von ganz alleine
wobei so richtig hübsch aussieht dann
verschließen
dann kommt da gleich noch ein
geschenkband drumherum
vielleicht eine kleine anleitung wie man
die monate herstellt das mache ich es
gleich noch sehr viel und jetzt zeigt
euch wie die limonade angerichtet wird
ich nehme jetzt ein paar böse
wir kommen in class sind zwei sektgläser
aber ich finde sie jetzt einfach richtig
hübsch aus zu einer richtig feine
limonade
ein bisschen sehr hoch
je nachdem wie intensiv sich die
monarchs sein soll jetzt einfach etwas
mehr mehr woche etwas weniger
jetzt könnt ihr gerne noch bedrohen
damit dazugeben und wer noch einen
zitronengeschmack möchte kann auch noch
betonen grafit reingeben einfach vom
stängel
[Musik]
jetzt natürlich noch ne lavendelblüten
und dann mit sprudel also mit
mineralwasser oder zum beispiel mit sekt
oder prosecco ausschließen
hab ich ja noch so einem farbverlauf
[Musik]
und jetzt darf ich natürlich probieren
gefeiert zum probieren wird aber
durchführen damit sich alles vermischt
allerdings total intensiv ich würde zwar
noch ein bisschen mehr wasser auf diesen
ich mag gerne nicht ganz ist und der
lavendel geschmack also wirklich der
hammer hat o'neal am ende limonade
probiert aber ich sag jetzt mal meine
lieblings limonade und wie werde ich mit
sicherheit öfter machen
also fasst jetzt auch lust auf dieses
rezept bekommen hat habt geht auch felix
wälzt der erste noch mal ganz genau
probiert die sind lavendel sirup aus ich
werde mit sicherheit auch mal zum backen
verwenden
und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel
spaß machen mehr noch einen guten
appetit und uns allen frosch
ich glaube ich verschenke ich auch
[Musik]